the number one thing that you need to do
as an entrepreneur is follow your
passion hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe
that hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
and today amazing a question from one of
my Twitter followers harmonia media who
wrote in to say happy to connect Evan
it's happy to connect with you too love
that you help entrepreneurs that's what
I love to do what's your main tip for
newbie entrepreneurs so for those of you
who watch my channel for a long time
you've probably heard this message
drilled into you over and over and over
again but you need to love what you do
you need to be passionate about your
business and that needs to show and
everything that you do I love helping
entrepreneurs I hope that comes across
it sounds like you understand that
message because you wrote it in your
tweet everything I do almost is about
helping entrepreneurs and it fuels me it
gets me excited you need to find that
for your business it's not just about
making money the people who start a
business just to make money they never
do they end up losing our shirt you lose
all your money because starting the
business is hard and you're gonna quit
as soon as it gets hard the only thing
that keeps you going is your love for
what you do if you look at any famous
entrepreneur and how they got started it
wasn't easy and their motivation was
never I want to make a lot of money sure
hey it's entrepreneurs we want to make a
lot of money right I'm not saying start
a charity I'm not saying it give it all
away I want to make money usually want
to make money that's part of business
but it can't be the main thing that
you're going after you've got to have
another reason for starting this
business you've got to feel it it's got
to come through and everything that you
do when you find that then you're on a
roll then you have something to build
around and to make money you have to
offer value the more you're helping
people the more value that you're
offering the more money you're going to
make it's so critical and so many
entrepreneurs get it wrong they jump
into some network marketing opportunity
or their hot tip from a friend to jump
on this new business idea those can work
but you have to love it network
marketing works when you love what
you're selling if you don't love what
you're selling it's not going to work
doesn't matter how great it looks on
paper
you have to love what you're doing and
it has to help people that's your start
find that angle find your passion when
you do that and you start a business
around that you're going to make a lot
of money and you're going to have a lot
of fun as well on top of making an
impact good luck let me know how you're
doing and congrats um wanting to start a
business for those of you watching if
you liked the video you know the drill
please give it a thumbs up below I love
seeing those come in and here I want to
hear from you if you have a comment on
this video or question for your own
business please leave it in the comments
below I love seeing those come in and
i'll make a video reply for you so thank
you guys and i'll see you on the next
episode